[Musique]
alain claude lagier bonjour bonjour
monsieur ko il est bon jour aux
auditeurs de martinique 1ère candidats
au second tour de l'élection municipale
au françois alla claude lagier dit
claudie ac c'est bien ça la vôtre alors
alain claude lagier pour le second tour
qui arrive 126 voix à peine vous sépare
de votre concurrent un principal qui
vous talonne samuel tavernier et 1353
voix d'écart en revanche avec l'autre
concurrentes dans cette course au
fauteuil de maire du françois karine
rousseau alors à l'aune de ces résultats
que je viens d'indiquer parce que vous
vous avez recueilli tout de même 37 92 %
des suffrages exprimés soit 2332 vote
donc voilà donc 126 voix de séparation
avec samuel tavernier 1353 voix d'écart
avec karine rousseau à l'aune de ses
résultats à l'issue de l'ag comment
envisagez vous la bataille de ce second
tour du 28 prochain offrant soit assez
facilement
d'abord permettez moi de remercier un lé
2332 franciscains qui ont porté leur
choix sur notre liste
c'est vrai qu'ils nous ont fait
confiance nous sommes sortis en tête et
nous sommes convaincus que la suite sera
aussi favorable alors pourquoi parce que
effectivement l'écart est mince tout de
même avec samuel tavernier
oui mais les kms pourquoi simplement
parce que le coc vie 19 est passée par
là et que je crois énormément d'appels
de franciscaine de franciscains qui me
disent qu'ils sont vraiment désolé de
n'avoir pas pu venir voter donc ce
chiffre s'explique par l'effet qu'ovide
la peur que je comprends pas en fait
vous estimez que vous avez une réserve
de voix mais les autres aussi peut être
écouté il suffit de comparer les
résultats
en 2014 le mpf au premier tout fait 4000
voix c'est être avec mon 810 en tête qui
a effectivement une notoriété
considérable à l'époque et 4500 voix au
deuxième tour
et aujourd'hui nous en faisant 2300 donc
il ne s'agit pas de dunes
d'une d'un manque de confiance au
contraire je crois que d'ailleurs
lorsque je passe sur le terrain depuis
le déconfinement et bien les gens sont
désolés vraiment de n'avoir pas pu venir
et je les comprends parce que c'est vrai
que il y avait une peur qui green ya se
montre précisément avec l'au-delà gier
le défi maintenant pour vous c'est
comment finaliser justement de
convaincre ses franciscaine et
franciscains de confier un nouveau
mandat de maire de premier magistrat de
la commune un candidat issu d'une équipe
qui gère la ville depuis deux décennies
maintenant mais je crois qu'ils sont
déjà convaincus
lorsque vous sautez en tête au premier
tour c'est bien le signe que la
population adhère et la d re pourquoi
parce que d'une part le mpf quoi qu'on
dise quoi qu'en disent les opposants n'a
pas démérité vous avez une ville qui a
considérablement progressé pendant les
25 dernières années et donc c'est le
premier le premier effet est la deuxième
chose c'est que nous sommes aujourd'hui
une équipe totalement renouvelée
aujourd'hui vous avez
candidat tête de liste il ya 47 ans vous
avez quelques personnes d'expérience de
l'ancienne liste qui sont présents mais
aussi beaucoup de nouveaux
deux jeunes les plus jeunes aux 25 ans
sur la liste par exemple et donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de laisser une nouvelle
génération prend des responsabilités et
c'est ce à quoi nous nous employons et
je crois que les franciscains ont
compris le message
ils l'ont très bien compris et vous faut
aller au delà de l'étiquette mpf
mouvement populaire franciscain faux nom
mais le mouvement populaire franciscain
je voulais dit et quand même le
mouvement qui qui qui règne sur la ville
depuis 25 ans c'est pas par hasard il la
dernière fois c'était quand même des
donc c'est une difficulté pour vous ça
non c'est âge il ne faut pas le prendre
comme une difficulté au contraire si
vous voulez c'est quand même une
expérience acquise personnellement
auprès du maire j'ai été directeur de
cabinet pendant deux ans donc c'est une
expérience qui qu'on fera valoir durant
le mandat à venir
alors pour terminer comment allez vous
opérer pour transformer donc les serres
pour ainsi dire du premier tour au
françois halin clos de la ji comment
comment on fait campagne dans ce
contexte à me aussi particulier quand
même c'est vrai que c'est particulier
mais c'est vrai que les franciscains
sont heureux de nous voir puisque nous
allons contacter nous n'avons j'ai
d'ailleurs jamais interrompu le contact
durant le convive nous avons gardé le
contact à distance évidemment puisque
nous étions nous-mêmes confiné et donc
les franciscains sont heureux d'un
nouveau je vous dis ils sont désolés de
l'art pas pu voter donc ils sont
déterminés à faire ce qu'il faut le 28
juin prochain et a porté à la tête de
cette équipe que j'ai l'honneur de mener
qui est la nouvelle dynamique pour
servir le françois merci alain claude
delage y est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et rendez vous donc le 28 juin
prochain pour le second tour donc des
élections municipales au françois voilà
que je vous précise quand même que les
quatre premières émissions donc ont été
réalisés par adel le doux qu'on remercie
donc infiniment voilà bonne journée à
vous je vous remercie
[Musique]